et maintenant
quitte même à être plus précis mardi
kevin weeks as
me schilling bri voilà ce que pierre
dites-vous bas et boucle
mais
et voilà ce que dit pierre pour s'y
engouffrer linaf a aussi gagné 6,6
souvenir ça va pas mal c'est lamentable
comme d'habitude fait cet homme sait
combien ma saison je la tenais à vous
arrivez du théâtre edouard vii tous les
deux là ben oui vous répétiez oui c'est
vrai il en est fier vous savez votre
texte en gros oui
ouais ça va j'ai l'idée c'est dans la
vallée on doit aller oui et où ça va ça
se présente bien histoire
alors donc la pièce que nos amis répète
en ce moment s'appelle lune de miel de
noël coward c'est un grand classique du
théâtre british on peut dire et s'est
adaptée par eric-emmanuel schmitt et
s'est mis en scène par bernard murat
donc jusque là c'est la dream team
non en plus moi qui sont les vrais donc
ça ajoute à la qualité d'homme de nîmes
dans ce métier des gens qu'il usurpe
paul le guen pierre arditi qu'est venu à
15 m de long dans les chiottes et un
jour je n'écoute pas fier voilà alors
comment ça va c'est lamentable bien on
va raconter un petit peu d'histoire de
la pièce très loin de cela au moins le
pitch donc donc ce après vous être aimé
passionnément enfin je veux dire dans le
dans la pièce après bien sûr après vous
êtes aimés passionnément vous est
divorcé il ya cinq ans chacun refait sa
vie de son côté et ses remarques les
chacun de son côté or pendant c'est bien
l'idée pendant la première nuit de la
lune de miel
vous découvrez l'un et l'autre que vous
êtes dans le même hôtel et vous êtes
complètement paniquée vous voulez fuir
mais vos nouveaux partenaires
comprennent pas pourquoi voulez vous
vous en aller et voilà et donc ils vont
s'en suit une histoire rocambolesque et
je vous laisse imaginer on va pas
raconter la suite
enfin disons que c'est un point de
départ assez intéressant non c'est joli
comme c'est joli comme idée maintenant
très bien que ce qui est encore mieux
c'est qu'ils n'ont sûrement ils ont dans
le même hôtel mais ils sont dans deux
appartements mitoyens
le conte est pratiquement commun quand
ils sortent il sourit je trouve un 200 m
dos et qui est pratiquement le théâtre
parce qu'on peut voir les gens de fass
est possible
ben oui toi bien on voit les deux
parties ça très intéressante à j-15
c'était foutu c'est pas con au niveau de
la scénographie bien marré là on est
bien ma réseau sanguin laurent baffie
qui est quand même un dramaturge lui
aussi je crois qu'on peut le dire c'est
vrai qu'on peut le lire on peut le dire
sans en rougir un cinéaste a également
fait un film qui a fait son succès on
peut heureusement vous avez fait un
petit bout dans le queens de l'an parce
que sinon je joue parce qu on
retiendrait de votre et d'ailleurs ça a
boosté un peu ta carrière sam à faire ça
m'a fait un travail est un peu comme la
ficelle était un peu à peu dans le
et voilà elle a sorti la sphère bikini
est revenue au top il est au top là au
top
voir mon pierrot qu'est ce qu'on peut
dire d'autre sur la pièce aux gens d'y
aller évidemment parce que tout ce que
j'ai dit là ce ça ne peut que donner
envie il en a fait un film de sa déjà
parce que c'est un scénar de gens qui
n'ont pas fait de films de cette pièce
de khobar pièces d'un film lubitsch a
fait un film de design for living canada
3 qui est une très jolie pièce c'est les
deux pièces les plus célèbres de coward
mais la bbc a tourné ce lac des acteurs
prestigieux noms attendant la
distribution d'origine y avait qu à eux
mais il ya aussi laurence olivier ce
qu'on peut dire maintenant il est décédé
c'était pas très bonne est celle
approuvé cette définition c'est très
joli c'est joli alors on dit toujours
que coward c2c le guitry anglais mais en
réalité c'est pas tout à fait sans qu'on
crie c'est très très esprit français
très brillant très filant coward sait on
est plus sur les sentiments la
psychologie humaine c'est très gracieuse
et très glamour en même temps c'est
peut-être plus cruelle j'ai vu mes
vignes chez michel drucker et quelques
temps on nous a demandés il vous a
demandé quelque chose de très grave
il nous a dit est-ce que c'est pas
difficile de jouer avec l'homme dont on
partage la vie ça il fallait y penser
c'est la présence vraiment au regard de
sa bizarre et wiener si vous pouvez me
dire truc devrait pâtir une interview
trop premières dont je vais vous
épargner
non monsieur d'une bonne question plus
c'est vrai mais répondait
c'est très bien le dimanche après midi
c'est bien tu vends copenhague descendus
des objets formidables et oui la vérité
mais j'aimerais bien la faire cette
émission des gens qui ont des amis mais
c'est ça tout les ennemis deviennent
dire que tu es génial tu crois que moi
ça marcherait pas attendre a tendance à
s'étirer le 9 10 minutes vous êtes du
ministre alors je répète encore une fois
que tout le monde soit bien au courant
c'est le 6 février donc date historique
s'il en est odland voilà au théâtre
edouard vii et ça s'appelle et c'est le
siècle et briller au théâtre edouard
cissé